so it's just past 15 hours GMT and 6 p.m
in Moscow where investigators say they
have officially confirmed that Wagner
Chief devgan in precaution is dead seven
passengers and three crew members on
board the executive jet that crashed on
Wednesday have been identified through
genetic tests the statement by Russian
authorities comes after days of
speculation and rumors about the fate of
precaution once a close Ally of
President Vladimir Putin he led a failed
mutally against military leadership in
Moscow two months ago Dr Jabari begins
our coverage now from Moscow
the confirmation the world was waiting
for the official announcement of the
identities of the seven passengers and
three crew members killed in the plane
crash on Wednesday evening Russia's
investigative committee says the names
of the passengers on the flight manifest
match the bodies recovered from the
crash site
molecular genetic examinations have been
completed as part of the Criminal Case
of the airplane crash in the survey
region according to the results the
identities of all 10 victims have been
established they correspond with the
list stated in the flight manifest
meanwhile on the streets of the capital
Nick's reaction to the news of the plane
crash
yes it's good because traitors end up
like that we don't feel sorry for
traitors
of course it's a Pity he was a hero of
Russia it's always a Pity to lose such
people
I think it is a tragedy a human tragedy
and a tragedy for society he was a cult
figure people knew about him
many ordinary Russians have paid
spontaneous tribute to pagosian
memorials like these have been popping
up across Russia this is the church of
Saint Maxim the Confessor in the heart
of the capital it's been turned into a
makeshift Memorial site for the members
of Wagner group who died in the plane
crash this is both a testament to the
popularity of evgeny pagosian and a
message to officials that despite
efforts to downplay the importance of
his death his legacy will continue to
live on as many questions remain
unanswered not only about his death but
also about the future of one of the most
notorious mercenary groups in the world
dorsa Jabari Al Jazeera Moscow
all right let's get more analysis from
mountainzibari whose life has joins us
live now it's also what happens next
then
well Nick there's still a lot of
questions that remain unanswered even
though this verification has been
important the confirmation that if
getting progression was on board that
flight that went down into via region
about 300 kilometers north of Moscow on
Wednesday evening we still don't know
what caused the crash the investigation
continues into the uh into the reason
the plane went down and also we're
waiting to find out about what will
happen around the funeral of Afghani
pagosian and his right hand man Dimitri
utkin who was on board that plane as
well it's very important to point out
that the Russian President Vladimir
Putin talks about his relationship with
evgeny progosian on Thursday where he
mentioned the two men have known each
other since the early 1990s and when the
spokesperson for the Kremlin was asked
Dmitry peskov on Friday about whether or
not Vladimir Putin would attend the
funeral of Ferguson peskov said well the
president has a very full schedule and
it's still unclear whether or not he
would be able to attend them we still
don't know
whether his family would have a public
funeral or a private one that's still
something we're waiting to find out the
other important thing is we are waiting
to hear more from the um PMC Wagner
group itself the mercenary group has
been meeting we understand having a
number of high-level meetings about
making decisions about the future of the
organization and the power structure
that will follow for goshen's death so
even though this news is important I
think we still have a lot of questions
that remain unanswered for now all right
dorsa thanks for that Dr Jabari there in
Moscow
so let's take a closer look at the
embryo 135 flight that crashed on
Wednesdays seven passengers and three
crew members were on board the executive
Jet and they included evgeny precaution
himself the head of the Ogden group and
Dimitri Atkin Dawson was just talking
about him his close Ally and co-founder
his call sign Wagner gave the group its
name and then there was Valerie chakalov
a senior Deputy precaution who was in
charge of Wagner's Logistics let's take
this on lots of questions posed Peter
elstof joins us now from North Carolina
he's associate professor at the U.S
national defense University Peter great
to have you with us first up a question
we have to ask I think is does this
actually end all speculation about
preggers death or is the book in any way
still open
well if you look at some of the uh
channels that our telegram channels uh
there's a lot of conspiracy that he is
alive and that just shows
um how popular he is and he's becoming
this like kind of iconic uh hero for a
lot of his followers there are some uh
conspiracy stories that he's been
recently seen in Mali and the photos of
him were posted where allegedly or
African leaders
um I'll thank him for saving democracy
in Central African Republic but I mean
he's clearly dead and it's clearly an
assassination because Putin could not
tolerate him I mean this was an
incredible embarrassment for him to see
that Rebellion uh there are also
sentiments in some telegram channels
that he shouldn't have stopped uh on his
uh path to Moscow so he's definitely
becoming a heroic figure and the big
question is is whether the Wagner group
uh will uh accept the new command
because they will have to send someone
put someone in charge of them and that's
the thing isn't it so so he's clearly
dead you say what happens to Wagner now
because uh if he's dead and Dimitri
utkin is number two is dead precautions
right hand man who fills that void
well we don't know but Putin will have
to take care of that and that person of
course will have to uh be under the
command of
um uh General garasimov and uh uh the
Minister of Defense uh Putin is not
going to let anyone to have that
autonomy for the Wagner group but the
question is of course or will they agree
to that because there is a force of tens
of thousands very well armed and trained
men with a criminal background most of
them come from prisons particularly most
recently uh so it's a very big question
whether they're gonna
um I'll actually be integrated into the
Russian military machine or they're
going to maintain uh some Independence
and that poses a huge problem for Putin
and if they are integrated into the
Russian military machine what does that
mean for Russia's ventures in places
like Africa in West Africa and so forth
because then in theory you'd actually
have Russia itself not a mercenary Army
uh fighting on the ground in Africa
well it is a mercenary Army but uh
they're not like a terrorist group
because they are actually a mercenary
Army under the command of Putin so there
is no dissent they can make their own
decisions and and what happened they
started doing it uh started thinking of
himself as a as an actual commander who
could have his own agenda and that's
what cannot be tolerated by Putin but
again the question is that whether he
will be able to subdue them
is that Peter just uh what kind of you
talk about the mood that there has been
in terms of the response on Telegram and
so forth what else has been said
dating him though they are portraying uh
with him as a hero uh but there are some
quotes assigned to him I don't know if
it's true or I wasn't able to reaffirm
that where for example
um there is an alleged quote from
precaution where he says that Russia is
on the edge of a catastrophe or
basically disintegration and he seen
like a person who could save Russia so
it's clearly no one is praising gerasima
for shoigu they are not portrayed as
Heroes uh on those channels so he's seen
as a hero like for example he's also
quoted as he is as a saver of democracy
as I said in central
um or African Republic uh he is also uh
shown and been quoted as he says the
president is uh uh is mistaken we are
not Traders we are heroes and we are
patriots so this is a general mode uh
there is not an order of criticism of
course this
um uh channels would be attribute or two
different players I think the FSB may be
involved the ukrainians may be involved
so it's difficult to determine who
stands behind all of those channels but
they definitely do present a big problem
for Putin do you think Putin is now in a
stronger position because of
progortion's demise
no definitely not because there could be
another precaution coming and also if
you look at the morale of the Russian
army it's not good there's been suicides
among some more officers and probably
some more who are owning suicides
because this war is a disaster and what
the most uh humiliating thing for Putin
that um progression actually said during
his Mutiny that the war was useless he
actually undermined the entire cause of
the war he said that the war was not
fought the right way that uh it was
fought for own causes and basically that
was the biggest humiliation for Putin
and I don't think that those
soldiers in the Wagner group The
Mercenaries they I they don't seem to me
to have that deep allegiance to the
Kremlin that's the most dangerous thing
for them there could be another
precaution coming out of there
is great to get your perspective on this
we do appreciate that thanks very much
indeed join us there from North Carolina
in the United States thank you thank you
very much it was a pleasure thank you
what's the problem